let's now bring in former vice president
Mike Pence his book so help me God is
available now we have lots of news on
this Monday morning Merry Christmas to
you sir thanks for being here Merry
Christmas good morning you know we just
did a story an interview with a
gentleman who's uh was a special
immigrant Visa holder from Afghanistan
his brother is was trained by us to be
an elite forces Commando he's now he
made his way through the southern border
he's being held in a prison here's what
his brother said to us just now what
he'd like to tell President Biden watch
here
the people that come to the borders
without any vetting they're being
released but my brother comes with a
background a clear background he
deserves uh recognition for his service
not to be in prison and not to be
tortured by a country that he stood
alongside I wondered what you think
about this because it you take the
Afghanistan withdrawal chaos the
problems that we have at the border it's
this Confluence of an aptitude resulting
in this man being in prison what do you
think should happen to him yeah Danny
you couldn't say that better it is a
Confluence of ineptitude I mean to think
about a heroic Afghani Soldier who's who
who risked his life and his family's
life to stand with our soldiers being
relegated to having to go to South
America to join this massive movement
North the border and then he's the one
that we put in jail when he crosses the
Border it it it really is extraordinary
and I I hope the administration is
watching and moves quickly to remedy
that situation with him we owe a debt of
honor and gratitude to every one of the
Afghan soldiers that stood with the
brave men and women that fought in
Afghanistan on our behalf over those 20
years but that being said let me tell
you I was down to the Border twice over
the last year
and the most jarring thing that I heard
more than nine months ago was that the
cartels are in operational control of
our border today literally I stood in
Cochise County at a section of the
Border where literally on day one
President Biden ended construction of
the border wall and so you see all these
girders laid out in the sunshine rusting
in the sunshine in a hundred yards
across the border you could see a
lookout Nest to the cartels that they
literally decide
and you see that other people go down
there inside that and Dana and I have
been talking about why the rest of the
media has not been reporting on this up
until really about the last week about
the last and now when the by
Administration came in there was this
thinking that they want to do the
opposite of whatever you and former
president Donald Trump did and and maybe
it was a you won't do DACA so we're
going to allow this to happen maybe it
was the Border policies of separating
families so we're going to do the
opposite of that can you help us
understand why the Administration has
been so
um you could call it inept or you could
call it no refusal to do something yeah
I don't call it an app it's it's
operating exactly as those that Advocate
open borders wanted it to operate I mean
look we we ended uh illegal immigration
and Asylum abuse by 90 percent under a
combination of a border wall internal
enforcement the remain in Mexico policy
uh that I negotiated on the president's
behalf with Mexican officials and title
42 that we put into effect in those
early days of the coveted pandemic the
combination of those things ended the
crisis at our border but when Joe Biden
took office and the open borders crowd
was in the saddle in the Congress and in
the White House how did they benefit all
of that
from how did they benefit from open
borders I I you know I would leave that
to us I don't like speculating on
people's motives but I'm somebody that
believes that a nation Without Borders
is not a nation but my hope is it's
seeing 15 000 people come in
in a single week in El Paso having the
Democrat mayor of El Paso declare a
state of emergency might just jar this
Administration into
holding off on undoing title 42 which
was incredibly effective under our
Administration and for heaven's sakes
the remain in Mexico policy was just
common sense president Trump made it
clear there would be consequences if
Mexico did not step up and agree to
allow people to wait in Mexico when they
applied for Asylum we stood firm we
accomplished that we can secure our
borders
leadership the one thing that they're
very focused on though and is the
January 6 committee and the committee
now says that they have enough evidence
they say sufficient evidence to charge
president Trump here's Adam Schiff the
Democrat from California on that
I think that the evidence is there that
Donald Trump committed uh criminal
offenses in connection with his efforts
to overturn the election
um and viewing it as a former prosecutor
I think there's sufficient evidence to
to charge the president there's been a
build up to this moment what do you
think of it
well I've said many times having lived
through that day at the Capitol Dana
that
January 6 was a tragic day but thanks to
the courage of law enforcement
the violence was quelled we reconvened
the same day and finished our work under
the Constitution
of the United States but I must tell you
from very early on I've been
disappointed in the partisan nature
of the select committee on Capitol Hill
I mean to have a committee that was
literally appointed in its entirety by
the Democrat Speaker of the House really
violates the history and tradition of
the Congress the United States you may
not remember in 2007
I was the ranking member on a select
committee that looked into voting
irregularities that had taken place on
the floor of the Congress we had proper
representation of both political parties
all political parties were allowed to
ask questions of witnesses we produced a
report at the end and uh
this select committee from the very
beginning has has represented a kind of
a partisan taint that I think it's one
of the reasons why so few Americans are
paying much attention to what will
happen today or to the results or
recommendations of this committee let me
just
um if you feel that way and answered it
that way yeah then you don't believe it
should be a criminal case that should be
for to the Department of Justice well is
that what you're saying well I wrote
this in my book that how many times Adam
Schiff said that there was evidence of
collusion with Russia two and a half
years we listened to Adam Schiff talk
about evidence that he had seen that
that was never there let me let me be
very clear about this point
Congress has has no formal role in
justice department decision so they can
make recommendations today but when it
comes to the Justice Department's
decision about about
about bringing charges in the future I
would hope that they would not bring
charges against the former president I I
don't look I as I wrote in my book I
think the president's actions and words
on January 6 were Reckless
um but I don't know that it's it's
criminal to take bad advice from lawyers
and uh and so I hope the justice
department is on that too right so we'll
we'll see on that well but Dana I want
to tell you I I I hope the justice
department understands the magnitude of
the very idea of sure indicting a former
president of the United States I think
that would be terribly divisive in the
country at a time when the American
people want to see us heal
at this time of year we're all thinking
about the most important things in our
lives our faith our family and my hope
is the justice department will think
very carefully and your whole family
will be together for the for all the
families getting together for the first
time in three years you told us which
will be very exciting and you you wrote
the book we've read that you are
considering your future political had
this headline today is just Politico
right it says Pence has a huge problem
he's struggling to find his path back to
the White House do you think you would
make a decision after the holidays as to
whether you would get in for the
presidency and if not the presidency
would you be open to running in that
senate seat in Indiana
well I would tell you I've had the
privilege of serving in Congress in the
House of Representatives
governor of Indiana and vice president
of the United States is an incredible
privilege for me and
my family is going to take time over
this holiday season when we're all
together for the first time in three
years to give prayerful consideration to
where we might next step forward to
serve our country but for us it's always
about a calling let me know if if you
read my book Dana and I'd be honored if
you did you'll find early in my
political career I allowed my ambition
to get ahead of my Christian faith what
I thought my faith required of me in the
Public Square but the last 20 years it's
been about a calling and about trying to
respond to that call so we're we're
going to listen to One Another We're
going to pray we're going to continue to
listen to the American people and
sometime in the course of the next year
I think we'll be able to discern that
and I promise the senate race at all a
possibility
you know I served as president of the
senate for four years and that was a
great privilege is that enough for us I
I would tell you that the extraordinary
experiences that we've had in our life
uh the response that we've gotten to
telling our story in my book so help me
God the encouragement from around the
country has us just thinking about maybe
maybe one more season of service and uh
that's the one we're focused on okay
we'll put you down as a maybe
I took it as a no
yes for the possible White House run but
maybe a no for the Senate one uh I think
if if uh if if we were ever to step
forward to serve the American people it
would be to take all the experiences
we've had and and run for national
office and uh and but I'm always humbled
to be asked you know somebody asked me
the other day if I ever
thought about running for president and
I said no more no less than any other
kid that grew up with a cornfield in his
backyard so thank you for your time have
a good holidays thank you for coming in
today I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm means Lee Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis